[Music]
John if I may call you John you believe
passionately you believe passionately in
the Mayan apocalypse you thought the
Mayan apocalypse was going to occur and
that the world was going to end how long
ago was this 20 2012 2012 I no longer
believe in it quite as passionately as I
do I'm beginning to think the Mayans may
have been wrong okay that they were
dummies yeah they couldn't even make
smooth pyramids I don't know why I was
so you were not no you no longer believe
has your life changed at all now that
you no longer believe that your death is
imminent
well I've started setting small fires
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and I'll tell you something Wiz Kalifa
won't I have begun experimenting with
marijuana years old decided I'd give it
a try just started now at 43 well I
never did drugs before because I was a
good kid you know surely any child yeah
exactly not I have no problem with drew
I've been sucking on an asthma inhaler
since I was yay high yeah what I mean
sure and occasionally I'd indulged as
anyone would and a handful of you know
painkillers swiped from your wife after
she had a c-section you know what I mean
normal stuff those are pills that
science you know that's good but ok so I
don't think she needed them ok
marijuana is unseemly you know because
that's like you dig that out of the
ground I think like don't they have pigs
root around for it in Italy no no those
are truffles
I think the marijuana pigs are no
there's no marijuana they're eggs
they're owned by hippie druids now
they're not home by really pretty sure
I'm right on you're wrong about so much
here that's now it's different because
marijuana is being decriminalized and
the stigma is falling away yeah and the
science is catching up you don't burn
marijuana and a golden brazier like you
did in college what you do now is you
feed it to a very specific scientific
temperature until I think like the witch
ghost of intoxication comes out and
dances in your brain and here's the
thing these vaporizers that they're
using now are these beautiful consumer
electronic products yes and you know I'm
43 years old I have to start thinking
about you know my figure I I imagine
marijuana probably isn't as fattening as
my nightly martini gallon right so and
they're basically putting it into asthma
inhalers so how can I not do it do you
know what I mean either be part of
culture I'm gonna try it
alright well that's a good message to
get out there for the children
I mentioned I've been asked to plug the
Ragnarok survival kits are available at
John Hodgman calm these are survival
kits for the apocalypse that didn't
happen but alter your things you need
for societal collapse like survival
mayonnaise and a urine flask I usually
hear him flat yeah and and I decided to
launch my signature Cologne in this
because people would smell bad when
society disappears so there's my cologne
in there it's a real it's a real cologne
I worked it up with a real perfumer oh
goodness X and it's called it's it's it
was gonna be called ambergris I John
Hodgman based on the the stuff that
sperm whales secrete that they use to
make perfume yes but then I realized I
had a better name for it which is sperm
by John Hodgman okay I don't know much
about business but these are gonna sell
like are the whales yeah the whale
because of the whales yes
you